that's my first time in sentence so what
I want to talk to you about is I figured
I had a whole roomful of seminarians who
will rock either future priests and what
I'd like to take you through is you know
the theme of our of this conference is
duty and what I want to try to do with
you is try to unpack that a little bit
one of my contentions has been that the
our own tradition our artistic tradition
see the economic architecture the
liturgy it is a it is a way for us to
participate in the kingdom of God but it
isn't ends up also being an image of
reality itself
and it can help us to pierce help us
understand the way that the world
actually unfolds in front of us and we
can understand the world through the
lens of our tradition so what I want to
do is I'm gonna kind of take you through
the basics of iconography how you can
build I cannot go out of the very image
of Christ and how it kind of lays itself
out of it becomes the iconographic
program of the church it all works
together I'm not going to go too it's
not going to be something that I'm going
to go through in detail but rather than
it kind of gives you a glide and you can
follow and then explore on your own once
once we're done with it and so what I
want to start with is the basis so most
people know the Babli is the image of
the data says is any image usually that
has Christ in the center and then we'll
have saints on each side of Christ
sometimes you can have a row of science
like we do in the great Babli in the
iconostasis where you have a this this
row of saints that go all the way to the
end sometimes there are angels in there
as well and so the the
the notion of the dayss is one of the
oldest images that we have in
Christianity right away in the fourth
century when things started to open up
for Christians we see this image appear
even before the crucifixion for example
the crucifixion came much later in much
later let's say at least a hundred years
later in the in the history of
Christianity but some of the first
images we have are the images of the
Babli and what's interesting about the
Babli and this is this is why I'm
focusing on this is why I want to bring
you along this particular line is that
there's a way in which iconography
represents certain events and so you
have the icons of the feasts you have
the icons of the lives of the saints
icons of stories from the Old Testament
or from or from the story of Christ or
the story of the Virgin but there are
also there's also a manner in which
iconography represents the relationships
of beings to Christ the relationships of
beings to the logos so you can
understand a certain aspect of
iconography as an ontological hierarchy
as a hierarchy of beings that lead us
towards the source of their own being
and towards the culmination of their
coming together and that is of course
the image of Christ and so obviously
then some things will become evident
once you start to think about it that
way you're going to start to see why it
is that things are the way they are and
sometimes the way things are the way
they are it's it's so natural it's so
obvious that we don't even think about
it because it just it's just obvious to
have Christ in the middle right of
course you should have Christ in the
center of course it just makes sense but
it's important to understand it as well
especially in a world like ours which is
so fragmented and so decentered it's
important to understand what is that
Center and why it is that Christ is
there and how is it that it relates to
everything else and so this image
so this image is from an apse in Rome
four century one of the first mosaics
that we have so if you look at it you
have Christ you know it's it could be
almost an icon today
you have Christ sitting in the center he
is in glory he is pantocrator' he's
dressed as a noble Roman ultimately he's
dressed as the Emperor he holds in his
left hand he holds a book it could be a
scroll usually it could be a closed book
an open book but he's holding writing in
his left hand and in his right hand he
is gesturing he is blessing he is doing
he is there are different gestures that
Christ make but what's important is to
understand that he is gesturing with his
right hand
now this typology already existed in the
Roman times it was something that was
already there in the image of the
Emperor you would see the Emperor or a
an important senator or someone who had
who is important in society holding the
scroll in his left hand and gesturing
with his right hand and usually was a
gesture of address so the senator would
be addressing the the people and he's
holding in his hand this writing and
what it represented it represents two
aspects of reality and already I'm going
to start to point you in that direction
they have Christ in the middle and then
on each side of Christ is representing
complementary or opposite or aspects of
reality which mirror each other okay and
that's what we're going to start to see
as as this whole Babli unfolds and so
the the notion of the gesturing with the
right hand and holding the holding the
book or the scroll was in Roman legal
terms in Roman power was understood as
what we would say authority and power
and those two aspects were seeing
complementary and they would become the
basis of all legal systems in the Middle
Ages both in the east and the west so
you have something which is authority
and authority is direct it's related to
who you are as a person and so you know
the Senators had authority because they
were prominent because they
they had they had a important place in
society and then the other side power
was the actual legal documents which
gave that the capacity for someone to
enact that authority in the world so you
have a direct thing which is blessing or
addressing and then you have an indirect
aspect which is the written code the
written law which acts as a guarantee
for that which is said or that which is
brought directly so you can see that in
Christ and you can see it in our own our
own experience the bishop is there the
bishop blesses that's a direct thing he
is he is acting with spiritual authority
to give unto us and for us to to receive
from the bishop from the priest to
receive a spiritual relationship you
know and and that ultimately leads all
the way up to Christ but our tradition
also has the outer part which is all the
exteriors that we have we have our
canons we have the architecture we have
the liturgy all of these things are our
outer but both of them have to work
together you need to have an actual
relationship of people that have
authority that go all the way to Christ
we have this apostolic succession but
then that will end up manifesting itself
on the outside through these exterior
forms and you need both if you just have
one if you just have the exterior form
you have an empty vessel and if you just
have the authority part you have
something which doesn't have a body
let's say it that way
okay that lacks body so in this image
you have on one side of Christ you have
st. Paul and on the other side of Christ
you have st. Peter and those the first
Babli that's how usually what you would
see in that image on one side st. Paul
on the other side st. Peter and those
were called the pillars of the church we
still have that icon today that we even
celebrated in the Orthodox tradition st.
Peter and st. Paul standing together
holding the church together right the
two pillars of the church so why is it
that same
Peter and st. Paul are the two pillars
of the church I mean we have 12 13
apostles 12 plus 1 why is it that it's
them
and what I think is that I think it has
to do with who they are and it has to do
with this inner and outer direct and
indirect all of these complementary
relationships so we have to see Peter
and Paul as having a complementary
relationship now in this image you can
see that both both st. Peter and st.
Paul are being crowned can you see it
there's a female figure standing behind
them who are holding up crowns above
their head okay that is interpreted by
church historians by art historians as
being the two images of the church this
is something that we have lost a little
bit that tradition because we don't need
it as much anymore but in the ancient
church we had these two figures of the
church and here is it here's an image in
Santa Sabina where you have the two
images of the church you probably cannot
read the inscription but it is the
Church of the circumcision and the
Church of the Gentiles and so st. Peter
was the apostle to the circumcised and
st. Paul is the apostle to the Gentiles
okay so now think of it as I was trying
to explain Authority and power the inner
direct and the outer so now again you
have this relationship between inner and
outer you have the Jews who had been the
holders of the tradition and then and
they were the circumcised they were
those that had removed the outside
removed the outer flesh and and just had
the core right that's what that's the
ultimate symbol symbol of circumcision
and then you have now also the apostle
to the Gentiles and once you understand
that if you understand st. Peter as
being kind of this inner apostle and st.
Paul is being this outer apostle it's
going to help you understand a whole
bunch of things about st. Paul you know
st. Paul who represents himself as a
fool
he represents himself as a shapeshifter
he says I'm everything to all men he
boasts about his infirmities there's
this whole aspect of st. Paul which is
related to him being we could say and
start to talk in these terms now the
left side of Christ okay and Saint Peter
being what we call the right side of
Christ because one of the things you
have to understand is that image of the
of the day that image of the day Isis is
already right at the beginning is
already an image of the Last Judgement
the very first church decoration the
very first church programs were we're
all eschatological the the you know you
go to Rome and you see the very first
churches you can see like the 24 elders
and and all of these this imagery from
revelations as this bringing us into the
final moment the totality of everything
all right and in that totality of
everything that's when you get this this
ontological hierarchy that I'm telling
you about as everything has been
revealed you see everything in its place
right in its finality you see where
everything goes in the giant puzzle of
the cosmos and so this is one of the
also one of the very first images now
this is on a on a sarcophagus you can
see again can you recognize the figures
so so on our right is in the left of
Christ in this image is the image of st.
Peter and then on our left and his right
is st. Paul again can you see it all
right so now you have Christ who is
giving the law he's giving that book
that that power he's handing it over to
st. Peter right and so think about it
the way that I'm telling you about you
have Christ in the center he is the
logos he is that which is the origin of
everything that towards which everything
culminates and now he's handing
he's he's he's distributing to that
which is next to him right he's he's
distributing down the hierarchy you
would say so he's giving the new law to
st. Peter and he's standing this is
important he's standing on the cosmos
right so that figure down there with
with the the thing that's the cosmos
it's gonna it's gonna change but those
that's an early image of the cosmos I
just wanted to show you a few of these
now one of the images one of the
traditions that ends up developing and
this one the the sarcophagus of Junius
basses we don't know if that's what
happens because his uh one of his arms
is broken but one of the traditions that
ends up developing is the the
transmission of the keys as well so we
end up having two traditions a trend a
notion that there are the keys are
transmitted and also that the law is
transmitted okay and then all of that is
going to come together in an image which
is which is this one which is usually
st. Paul actually receiving the text and
st. Peter receiving the keys okay and
it's kind of you can you can see it at
the beginning it's kind of bubbling
everything's kind of coming together you
know at first it's a little awkward and
here you can see that st. Peter is
Christ is holding the key he has this
weird thing his hand and it has a key on
it and then in his other hand he's
giving a role he's giving this law to
Paul and he's giving the keys to Peter
so this is a later image but here it has
totally crystallized so you see st. Paul
is st. Paul is receiving the law and and
st. Peter's receiving the keys but with
what I'm trying to get to is here again
you have this image of that which is
direct or if I give you keys it's I'm
giving you the capacity to open and
close like like Christ said you have the
capacity to bless
and to curse to open and close it's a
direct authority like you as a person
you have that capacity and our bishops
have that capacity to bless and to curse
we have we have in the church that
capacity to do so but he's also on the
other side handing over the exteriors
the outside the the secondary or the the
the added which is this written text
this new law this form that is going to
be on the outside so once again you have
this inner authority and then this outer
form that comes to the outside okay all
right so I hope I hope that this is this
is starting to make sense I never know
if silence means that people don't know
where I'm going or if or if it means
that they're following me all right so
everybody knows where I'm going okay
cuz it's gonna get its gonna get more
complicated but okay so let me just this
is already going to start to account for
the basic structure of the church itself
right and so there are different ways of
doing it
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to show
you the different ways of doing it and
it'll help you understand why we have
different traditions and why those
different traditions just depends on how
what you're doing you can do you can do
it differently but they all end up
actually talking about the same thing so
the way that the the West especially
captured this idea was to have Christ in
the apse in the east right so we're all
facing Christ and there he is as this
place where we're all standing there
we're all looking we're all together
we're all joining together in order to
focus and to to participate in that
which what what we're looking at which
is that the divine logos in his absolute
manifestation as the judge of all as the
origin and finality of everything and he
is their blessing with his right hand
holding the book in his left hand and so
that's the so you can understand why it
would make absolute sense to have Christ
right there in the
because now we can imagine the Babli
right we're like a continuation of the
Babli you have Christ and you have all
the saints and so you can imagine you
can imagine all the stories and all the
saints on the sides of the church and
then we actually are inside that Babli
we're participating in it okay and
that's really important to understand
the participation part so in in the now
one of the things I want to just say one
thing that's difficult is that I'm gonna
talk about left hand and right hand and
it's very difficult to talk about that
because one of the problems with left
hand and right hand is that we have a a
clear symbolism of it in Scripture
where Christ talks about bringing the
sheep towards him and pushing the goats
away from him alright so you have this
bringing in towards the middle and then
this pushing away towards this towards
the edge you have so we have that
symbolism now the problem is how do you
represent it and that's where it gets
complicated because my right hand is the
left hand of Christ and his left hand if
I'm standing in front of you it flips
right and so at the beginning of the
church you get the things keep flipping
so it's like sometimes st. Peter is on
one side sometimes st. Paul is on that
side so it keeps going back and forth
one side and the other it's like as if
they're like do we represent it at the
right hand of Christ or do we represent
as the right hand as we perceive it and
so it's not it's at the beginning it
starts to its flipping around so don't
worry if you see it flipping at the
beginning but as the tradition kind of
settles you'll see that at some point
st. Peter is always on his right hand
and our church is like I don't think
I've ever seen a church where st. Peter
is not on the right and st. Paul is not
on his left there can be exceptions but
it's mostly that's mostly the way that
it's it's settled out today so now we
have the Babli after iconoclasm the east
if there are images of these days as
before I've never seen them it's hard to
know what was there before iconoclasm
but what we see coming out of iconoclasm
is that the east
jumps let's say develops a Babli which
is based on the mother of God and Saint
John the forerunner but in that you see
this is one of the first that we know of
that this the harborville triptych after
iconoclasm you see up in the top christ
the mother of god and Saint John the
foreigner but in this image we end up
having a very very similar structure as
the one that we had in the Diocese of
st. Peter and st. Paul
it's the emphasis is slightly different
but if you look at the images you always
have to look and try to see if there are
two figures that are complementary to
each other what is it that's
complementary about them and so if you
the great thing about the day is that we
use is that you have two characters two
two figures that were there before
Christ and pointed us towards Christ and
so right away we get the sense that
that's the whole point of this that's
the whole point of iconography right the
whole point of iconography is to do what
the mother of God and st. John did which
is to point everything towards Christ
all the images of the saints you know
although the Saints have participated in
God's glory they're all pointing us in
this this this great hierarchy towards
the source of everything so to have
Saint John the foreigner and the mother
of God as these two pointers is it's
it's a it's a beautiful decision let's
say but so on the one side what we have
we have the mother of God and she is
covered and we have st. John foreigner
and he was wild so wild hair wearing
animal skins out in the desert screaming
telling people to repent gets his head
cut off alright alright so did you have
an image of Saint John right st. Paul
also got his head cut off by the way and
then you have the mother of God who is
covered who is secret
who hid in the Holy of Holies whoo-hoo
you know every image about who gathers
in her heart there's that beautiful that
beautiful text in the gospel where it
says that that as she was seeing Christ
developed that she gathered all these
things into her heart right and that's
who she is she's the one who gathers
into her heart and then the logos
manifest himself in her heart in her in
her Center so now you have again these
two extremes have the outer chaotic
crazy hair wild animal all of this all
of this left-hand let's say let's
left-hand symbolism then you also have
the other side which is this gathering
and this bringing tours now think of it
think of the Last Judgement I think of
think of the Last Judgement those are
the two movements of the Last Judgement
there's one movement which is come and
there's one movement which is move away
now one of the things that I that I'm
contending from the beginning is that we
have a a manner in which that
relationship of come and move away which
is come towards the center being
positive move away from the center being
negative but there it's not necessarily
positive and negative there's also a way
in which coming towards the center can
be negative and there's a way in which
moving away from the center can be can
be positive right now in the case of
Saint Paul that he is a fool that he is
that he is a shapeshifter that he he
changes his his face depending on who
he's with that he that he boasts that he
bows from his weaknesses all of this
stuff you would say it's all negative
stuff but know Christ
turns it Christ turns that negative
stuff into glory in st. Paul right and
so to give you an example there's a
there's a is that one of my favorite
quotes quotes from st. Maximus is where
he talks about what he calls the sins of
the right hand and the sins of the left
hand and so he says that the sins of the
right hand are the sins of pride of
self-sufficiency
that type of sin and then the citizen of
the left are you know all the passions
of the bodies you know the sexual sins
and all that stuff that's the that's the
sins of the left and so he says that it
starts actually with the sins of the
right hand that at first you you get a
sin of pride and then that sin of pride
opens the door for all the sins of the
left hand to come in okay and so you can
see now if you take a carrot a right
hand character you take someone like
Saint Peter right what st. Peter's sin
that's right that's st. Peter since and
Peter's sin is I will never betray you
st. Peter's sin st. Peter his in his
fervor is how he falls in his fervor
right that's his fault he says I will be
I will get out of the boat he's the only
one who does it he's like I can do this
and sinks then he says I'm gonna follow
you until the end and denies okay so
like I said the the right hand is not
necessarily always positive the coming
and so you can understand it when I talk
about holding the center or coming
towards the middle right that is can be
an image of pride if you only hold to
your own right because it's our
identities that give us pride we think
it's like I'm self-sufficient I've got
everything I need I don't need these
other things so it's like I'm holding
into myself right and then sometimes God
will break that smash us splinter us in
order for us to understand that no the
the hierarchy keeps going after you my
friend there are things above you and
you need to submit to those as well
alright so here's that here's that one
of the first images of the Last
Judgement so we have the sheep on the
right hand and the goats on the left so
if I asked you Saint John the Baptist is
he a sheep or a goat which one would you
answer hard to answer because the goats
are negative in the story but yeah it in
terms of his type in terms of what he is
how he what he manifest he
the wild he's the wild aspect all right
so now of course this comes into us into
our into our tradition as becoming the
very shape of the iconostasis right so
we have we have Christ on his right we
have the mother of God on his left we
have st. John the foreigner and now look
at this image you notice how there is
the red angel on one side and the blue
angel on the other this is a
sixth-century image but we still have
that today still have that the even in
your even I've seen looked at some of
the icon estas is here in the chapel and
in the church and you still have that
Saint Gabriel on one side and Saint
Michael on the other so you can see I
just had an image to show you the red
angel at the end of the iconostasis and
then the blue angel on the end of the of
the other end of the iconostasis so this
is complicated because I'm not going to
talk about this but there is also a way
in which left hand and right hand
symbolism just like I'm standing in
front of you and it crosses like this
well you see that in icons as well or it
actually flips you see it in the icon of
the Transfiguration and you see it in
this icon which is a fire angel is on
the right hand of Christ but the goats
are on the left and the blue angel is on
the left hand of Christ but the sheep
are on on the right and so there's just
there's this interesting crossing that
happens in the later traditions you'll
see sometimes the red angel st. Michael
has a sword right and then the blue
angel San Gabriel holds it Lily alright
now this structure this basic structure
so now you're going to start to see that
it's it's it's everywhere because the
crucifixion is also that image the
crucifixion is has the same structure as
the Babli this is one of the first
crucifixions fifth-century so like a
hundred years there's about a hundred
years after the very first images
started to appear in the
in the force entry so why do we show the
three crosses in a full crucifixion
because it's in the story of course but
also because what are the two sides
right one side looks towards Christ and
the other side looks away from Christ so
here's one of the one of the first
representation another one of the first
ones where you see on Christ's right on
our right I mean you have the character
who is looking up towards Christ and
then on the other side you have the
character who is looking down or looking
away or not looking at Christ and you
see that if you look at later images of
the crucifixion like the full
crucifixions you will see you will see
that you'll see sometimes one is
actually turned backwards different ways
of showing that one is looking away and
one is looking towards and you have this
image of the one the thief that looks
towards Christ as being the very image
of this gathering in he is the ultimate
image of the gathering in because he
says to Christ today he says to Christ
he says to the thief he says today you
will be with me in paradise and if you
look at an image of the Last Judgment
there are a few figures that we show in
paradise and most usually we will show
the good thief in paradise as one of the
figures not just because he's in
paradise but as the first one to enter
paradise through Christ he becomes an
image of the very entering into paradise
of that coming into the holy place okay
now and this this structure again is
also the reason why we have this it's
the same thing so you ever wonder why we
have that tilted bar on the Russian
cross it's because of that there like
that cross will Christ is a balance
right because on one side it lifts up
and on the other side it casts down and
that's the image of the crucifixion and
that ends up being the image of
of the of the cross itself ultimately so
so when I'm talking to you about this
this aspect these two sides right and
you see it as in the very image of
Christ blessing and the book and st.
Peter and st. Paul and the red angel and
the blue angel and the mother of God and
Saint John the foreigner you know you
can see that it's it is really is this
pattern of how unity and multiplicity
exist it's an image of reality right
it's an image of how you can have
something which is one which brings us
together but also lets the many exist at
the same time you can you can think of
it this way you can think of it as
breathing in and breathing out so you
have breathing in breathing out Christ
brings towards himself and pushes away
from from himself but the pushing away
like I said it's not it can be negative
but it's not necessarily negative it's
also pushing away to go into
multiplicity it's also this pushing away
in the sense of sending the disciples
out to the ends of the earth right
that's also this kind of casting Oh
casting casting away in a positive sense
okay and so this is my pet peeve here
which is you will everybody and I'm sure
everybody has your opinion about this
icon and everybody who's in seminary has
heard about it and had their opinion and
you will hear the deconstructors who
will tell you that this image is just an
accident and if you look at it closely
you get a sense that maybe that I that's
a bit off you know on his left side is
maybe a bad paint job like they tried to
fix it and they didn't they didn't get
it right
and think that people are missing the
point doesn't matter what the mechanical
cause of this image is who cares like
when we say icons not made with hands
they still manifest themselves like it
doesn't matter how they manifest
themselves that's not the point right
the point is that when we look at
image of Christ and we see the two sides
and we perceive it we're not just
perceiving it in that image is because
we're perceiving the entire tradition of
iconography it's like it's there
everywhere so if we see it there and
people tell you no it's not there it's
like well it's everywhere else so why
does it bother you that it's there like
why does it bother you and it is it's a
if there's a kind of insidious approach
towards towards our tradition and
towards our history which is to try to
point out and it's like a I would say
it's like the BART airman school of
whatever you know it's like trying to
point out the historical accidents and
the historical causes as if that matters
as if that explains the the the meaning
of something like it can't participate
in the meaning but it doesn't explain it
right like if you find it like I using
again the image the images we have that
are not made with hands they're still
made of material they still materially
manifested themselves so if you can show
some kind of mechanical cause of you
know it's like oh it can't be an image
not made with hands because it's made of
wood okay that doesn't matter that's not
the point you're missing the whole point
okay all right sorry I'm gonna get off
my rant and I'm gonna go back into this
presentation okay so so you have the
basic dais you have Christ and you
remember the image of Christ with his
feet on the cosmos right there's this
this text in the end the Prophet which
is that right heaven is his throne and
the earth is his footstool and so now
what you can do and so what's gonna was
gonna happen to is instead of
representing this hierarchy like this we
have Christ in the middle and you have
all these things that come out that
let's say gather to him but also come
out of him you can do it like this I can
do it like a like a pyramid you can have
something above and then things below
which then come from that source above
head and body so now we have heart and
let's say periphery like center and
periphery like that terms of the Babli
but you can also have head and body and
that's when things start to look like
this so this is a call it a proto
ascension and now we're taking the same
idea and we're propping it up in a way
that we put Christ above Christ is going
up into heaven he's becoming the head of
the church and the church is there below
and manifesting him in the world so we
have Christ up in glory he's the Alpha
and Omega and then down here who do you
think is there you can probably guess
who's there who are the two figures on
the sides Peter and Paul and in the
middle it is debated who exactly it is
yeah you could say that it's ecclesia
that is the church but it doesn't matter
to us because ultimately that image of
ecclesia will become the mother of God
so whether or not it was explicitly
identified as the mother of God at that
time it doesn't matter because it's
exact I gonna graph ik structure that
we're going to come to the full
manifestation of the mother of God as
this image of ecclesia who is who is
below okay so in the text it doesn't say
that the mother of God was there at
ascension but we have to have her there
at ascension right because this image is
not just an image of ascension it's an
image of reality it's an image of the
way that the church exists it's an image
of all of the ontological relationship
of the Saints that gather together and
become the body of the head which is
Christ and you there's no other way to
see it because Paul wasn't there the
Ascension either and it's funny but he's
there in that image
like why is st. Paul in that image say
Paul is in that image because the
Ascension becomes the vehicle to show us
something which is revealing to us the
very manner in which the church exists
and you have to have st. Paul there
because st. Paul is that pillar he's
that outer pillar right the the in the
temple
in the temple there were two pillars
there is one which I forget the names of
the Jachin and Boaz I think the name of
the pillars were does somebody remember
the name of the yeah so yeah Qian and
Boas and one that one has to do with
let's say establishing and one has to do
with boys which is who married a
foreigner right so we don't even know
they don't exalt like it's funny that
his name boss he's the one who marries
this foreign lady so he is this apostle
to the Gentiles
you have the Gentiles on one side and
you have the inner Jews in the middle
like it was there I mean I'm telling you
about this but this is there this is
there from from yeah from creation say
that way I particularly like the images
of the Ascension that have the mother of
God on a footstool that's the best
because then you really get that whole
image of Christ sitting on his throne
and then you have the body the earth
which is down below as his footstool and
then he is sitting on a rainbow which is
the stone right is this image of heaven
above can you see that he's sitting on a
rainbow yeah right so so now what you
can do with this now you have this image
which is a great image then you can
actually you can spread it out into
space so you can take this take this
image and you can turn it into this
right it's the same image the same thing
the first representations of Christ in
the dome were actually representations
of the Ascension where you had the
disciples and the mother of God and then
you had Christ in the top and it was not
just the ascension but it was both the
Ascension and the eschatological moment
because as the angel said he will return
in the same manner that that he left so
to show showing the ascension that's why
I'm telling you that that image of the
ascension it's one of the best image
because it's an image of everything it
really is an image of reality it's
showing us the relationship of Christ to
his to his church as he is ascending to
become the head but also adds he's
returning to join in to join fully with
his body so it's also the the bride and
the bridegroom it's all of that is going
on in this image all right so how do you
turn it into this so you have at the
lower on the lower sphere you have in
the square which is the footstool which
is the nave you know we have this square
cross and then you have the dome which
is heaven which is the the rainbow and
all of that so you have the mother of
God in the apse who is who represents
for us now how all of this let's say
that how the footstool comes together
into her and then above you have Christ
in the dome so you can see that if like
if you don't have a dome for example I
mean it's totally fine to have the Babli
as we experience it to have Christ in
the east as the one who returns and then
have the unfolding of creation and the
Bible stories and the Saints on the
sides right we have that we also have
that - it's the great Babli when you're
standing in church and you're looking
and wait and you have the great Babli
and say if you have a very elaborate I
can assess this you're staring the same
thing that a Western medieval Christian
would have stared at in the 12th century
if Christ in the center in glory and
then you have this unfolding on the
sides and so they would have seen that
in the apse so I it so I think some of
most of the chapels here actually have
Christ and glory in the apse right so
these two parts these two ways are
they're manifesting the same thing
they're just you can pull it up into a
dome and then you have that fullness but
you can also bring it down in terms of
its you know of a that type of
representation okay
and so here if you look at this image
it's great
this is Josias Lucas and you can see the
apps with the mother of God and they put
a dome above the apse there's a little
dome above
apps and then there's the there's there
many domes in that church then there's
the giant dome which has Christ in glory
and above the the the app they had this
little dome and what's represented there
can you give you can you see somebody
guess what that is can you see well
sorry yeah but what's going on what's
coming down on their heads how about if
they I say that way his fan accost
alright so its pinnacle I sorry so yeah
and so you have this you really have
this image of so again so why why is st.
Paul at Pentecost
there's Saint Paul's not at Pentecost
and the story he's there because this is
to show you how it works it's that it's
to bring you into the very manner in
which the church exists and the very
manner in which we participate in that
so we that's why in our icon of
Pentecost we don't have we have st. Paul
and st. Peter that are there to show us
so in this this is a little different
like in this version you you have this
idea of the fire Pentecost coming down
on to the church so if you you were
there you would experience it you have
the dome of Pentecost and the coming
down and then under the dome with
Pentecost you have the mother of God
which is their stand in for all of us
standing for for for ecclesia and she is
there under this whole thing of
Pentecost now in our icon of Pentecost
we have the other figure remember we
have the mother God as the right-hand
figure in the sense of bringing
everything together but in our icon of
Pentecost we have the left-hand figure
we have the old figure of Cosmos in the
dark so now what we're we're the other
image is showing us how Pentecost is
this the sending of the Holy Spirit into
the communion of the saints and this
image is showing us how ultimately this
goes out into the ends of the world the
early images of Pentecost
actually had a crowd in the image that a
crowd of foreigners so had a bunch of
people dress in different garbs
representing all the different peoples
of the world and so that's that's st.
Paul right st. Paul going all the way to
the edge so you can have but it's
important to be able to distinguish
between the two it's really important
because some really creative iconography
sometimes I've seen recently a very
creative iconographer who put the Mother
of God down there it's like are you
putting the mother of God in the dark
outside on the edge of the world and I'm
not sure about that sorry ah she's in
the Holy of Holies she's she's not in
the out she's not outside she is the
very image of inside we always say the
mother God is a mystery of the church
like we keep her to ourselves you know
all right so a few more anybody keeping
time on me okay all right okay all right
so this is my last this smell image just
to show you how all of this all this can
come together in different ways it's not
doesn't always have to be exactly the
same it can so here is you could say how
reality is manifested in the crucifixion
and to have the crucifixion as the image
of everything because it is also the
Last Judgement is already there in the
crucifixion that's one of the reasons
why we have the good thief and the bad
thief has to help you understand that in
the crucifixion moment everything was
accomplished even the Last Judgement was
already accomplished in that moment
right and so you have Christ above you
have this crucifix fiction at the very
top of this hierarchy of images and now
it's it's almost you have to kind of
imagine as if in the crucifixion all of
this is happening like the image of the
Anastasis which we see underneath the
christ going down into death that's in
the crucifixion image now when you see
the blood of Christ going down and and
dripping on the skull of Adam that's
best
that it's like if you took that little
part of the icon on the crucifixion you
unfolded it what you get you get the ana
status so it's already in it's already
packed in there and we just open it up
and we you can yeah and then again the
same you have the icon of the Last
Judgement which is under the Anastasis
and is contained also Indiana status
right so you have Christ going down into
death getting Adam and Eve right and
then in the image of the Last Judgement
they probably don't have it in this one
yeah do that yeah they do they do he
comes in to death he takes Adam and Eve
he brings them to the Last Judgement and
there they are in the Last Judgement and
they're the standings for us as well so
all of this is gathered brought into the
image of the cross and so what I'm
trying to help you to see is that when
you have just the icon of Christ if you
have just the icon of Christ or if you
have just a crucifixion see in front of
you all of it isn't folded into that
image everything is folded in to those
moments we can unfold them and then we
unfold them we get this glorious
beautiful panoply of images that we fill
our churches with but if you are sitting
if you're at home and you are standing
in front of the image of Christ and
glory all of it is folded into that
image as well just as all of reality you
know is brought into the Incarnation
right into Christ okay and so what I
mostly wanted to help you do is just
also to get a sense of excitement about
about iconography and understanding that
the images we have they're not arbitrary
they're not they're not just a bunch of
separate images but rather the the
entire of iconography is really like a
symphonic thing it's it it is all the
images take their meaning from each
other and reflect each other and and
they they come together in a
of communion is the only way to say it
they they all come together into a kind
of communion to help us enter into the
life of Christ just as we do hopefully
the same when we when we're together and
when we're singing when we're worshiping
when we're loving each other all of this
is this image of how all of creation is
is brought together and held in Christ
so hopefully that was uh was helpful for
you guys to get excited about
iconography and and as you become
priests in your parish I encourage you
to take it seriously and to yeah to take
iconography seriously so I'll say thank
you and if anybody has any questions I
think we do have time for questions yes
all right if anybody has any questions
go ahead
[Applause]
wondering maybe if you can elaborate on
the end acuity in these different
aspects of symbolism because like the
two colors or not you know one symbolic
element here so the the first thing that
we have to the first thing that we have
to look at is that symbolism is not
moral that's the only thing I can say is
that the way in which reality exists is
not a not moral in the way that we we
tend to see more Olins in the sense of
this is good this is bad this is good
this bad like everything everything in
creation is is good if it's in its
proper place you know there's nothing
that is created which is evil in itself
and that is true of so much and so the
best thing that the devil can do is
distort and twist things but usually if
you're attentive you can you can also
flip it back and you can bring things
back to how they should be so the good
best example is upside-down cross with
that is that satanic of course not it's
the image of st. Peter right but can it
be satanic sure it's used in that
context it can be satanic an actual
cross can be satanic two people actually
you know they'll use or you know like
let's say a pentagram is a pentagram
satanic a pentagram is not satanic a
pentagram is a five-pointed geometric
shape right and so it can it can have a
it can be very a very powerful
representation of how four things go
into one you know you can imagine even
Christ with the four glories as a kind
of pentagram he has four glories and
then you have his head as that as the
head of the four glories right so it's
not there's nothing wrong with with
these signs but but like I said it
doesn't mean that they can't be misused
and that they can't be distorted and
that they can't be used for evil
purposes like you know just like
language itself is the way that God
created the world but we can use
language to hurt others and canler you
know we can use language to curse people
so so it's the same that's to me that's
always the way that I look at it I
always try to see like if I look at
something I always try to see it in for
I always try to see because usually if
there are two two things that Mayor that
like mirror each other I tried to see
the positive aspect on one side the
negative aspect the positive aspect or
the other side in the negative aspect
and I usually try to see it that way and
it I think it's it's helpful because you
know it's like the left hand for example
is usually sinister it usually is is
represented in terms of casting into
hell I mean you see it in glass judgment
it's casting into hell but but then I
mean okay so why is Saint Paul always on
Christ's left you know at some point
today John the foreigner like at some
point you also have to be able to see
that that if you if you ignore the
positive aspect of it then you're
actually going to miss an aspect of
reality and you're just it's just gonna
be blindly in front of you you won't
even be able to understand it all right
and that's one else yeah
well it's that symbolism like I said
because this is a symbol of reality it's
not it's not it's an image of reality
and in all identities work that way that
is not just the church every identity
has an inside and an outside if that's
just when an identity is and so in all
identities have a inside and a margin
something which is not quite inside and
not quite inside right and so we need to
we just I mean it can be used for good
and can use for bad it can be used to
cohere right so you you have this sense
that we have to we have to be able to
cohere but then we also have to be able
to look towards the outside so in our
church we have that we have our if you
look at the liturgy and you look at the
the architecture of the church it's a
moving in which also respects or makes
participate the outside too so we have
an Ardex and in the narthex you know
that's where the catechumens go when
they get chased I mean nobody does it
anymore but it's like when the
catechumens get chased they go to the
narthex and in the narthex we can
represent you know you see that in greek
churches until today
they'll put Plato and Aristotle and all
these characters which are kind of like
well are the inside or the outside
they can't be totally inside because I
mean you know there are pagans and all
that but they can't be totally outside
because then why do we use their
language to talk about the mysteries of
Christ so we have to find a place for
them they're there on the edge you know
what is it Dante put them in limbo so we
put them in the narthex or in this like
intermediary space right and and so so I
think that that can happen like you said
it can happen in terms of ethnic in
terms of ethnic communities where like
you said you have that opportunity which
is to have a group that you identify
with that you can celebrate the same
story the same history the same
you know hardships together but then it
can also be a problem when it becomes a
shut door that prevents you from
interacting with love towards your
neighbor right so it's neither good nor
bad
we just have to be it just depends on
how it's used okay so she asked about
the fact that in the Babli or in our
tradition now today we represent Christ
with a beard and if you look at the
older images in Rome especially you saw
a Christ as a young man as a kind of
young young kind of ideal Apolo figure
and so she asked how does that change
happen or why did it happen and does it
have to do with Zeus and what and the
powers okay so so the idea that Zeus has
this authoritative figure and then those
that are under him so so the the the
tradition of representing Christ as with
a beard and also represent Christ
without a beard seems that very early at
first it I'm not sure if it had a
specific meaning I think that at first
it seems to have been just you know like
okay so we represent a figure we don't
know what Christ looked like let's say
in Rome and we want to represent him in
a way that people understand what we're
talking about so this is how we
represent it in a kind of psychological
manner but quickly it actually came I
think to have meaning if you go to
Ravenna there's a there's a church where
on on one side of the church it's all
images of Christ without a beard and on
the other side of the church
all images of Christ of the beard it's
like that's obviously not like Justinian
isn't an idiot like you they didn't do
this just arbitrarily this obviously has
some kind of meaning okay and so the way
to understand it I think and what it's
come to mean in the Orthodox tradition
is that the beardless Christ which we
still have it's not true that we don't
have images of beardless Christ we have
the images of Christ Emanuel we have the
infant Christ right and so and then we
have images of Christ with the beard as
the adult represented as this kind of
crop in glorious figure even in when you
see in the images of his life he's he's
dressed as a senator obviously Christ
was not dressed as a senator when you
walked through Galilee but we represent
him that way in order to show us
something about who he is
and so I think that the way that it's
come to mean this is this is really an
interpretation is that we show Christ
implicit in terms of a child so we show
Christ the idea of the logos hidden in
the world or the Logie that are hidden
in creation that's why we show Christ in
born in a cave all of this imagery of
this hidden aspect of Christ
what is it logos perm atticus like Saint
Justin talks about the idea of the logos
hidden in creation and then we have the
logos who is fully revealed and fully
manifested so when we show Christ the
way we do it with the beard we're
showing the price the return in Christ
even when we're showing him in his life
so if we're showing about the wedding of
Cana we're still showing him as the
returning Christ in full glory I don't
that makes sense
so as Christ is being really it's the
the idea of the logos revealed and the
logos hidden does that make sense yeah
best way I can explain it yeah
and they're very telling as a kid but I
wonder why yeah so Benedict asked why
because we can express these things
conceptually we can explain them and
talk about them with ideas so why is it
important that we represent them
artistically why is it important that we
have them as images and I and I think
that there are there are few answers the
best answer would be participation
that's the best answer is that the
church is participative the church is is
not just sitting and thinking about
things and so the the image is something
you have to it has a place in the world
it it's taking up space and it's you
know it's it's reflecting light from the
world it's participating in creation in
a very bodily sense and so it it engages
us to participate it engages us to to
actually engage with this face of this
person and it's also because because
Christianity isn't a story of ideas
right Christianity is the story of
incarnation and so it's not it's so cool
when I say let's say that the left hand
or right hand and all this stuff it's
like st. Paul is manifesting that to us
he's making it real in the world and
that's what we have to do we can't just
think about it we have to we have to
incarnate the principles that ultimately
let's say originating Christ we have to
manifest them in the world so to me
that's that's that's what it is like it
has to has to come down to us and we
have to participate in
it's a thorn well st. Paul has a thorn
so what is it caught what is the so you
have this you go in the garden let's go
back into the garden so what's the first
sin what kind of sin is it it's a sin of
pride it's it's it's I am going to be
God and then what happens is they fall
and then what did the encounter thorns
I think counter thorns encounter the
hardships of the world they encounter
the passions they encounter the the
multiplicity gone wild right the demons
all the millions of demons that are
pulling us in all these different
directions and so st. Paul has a thorn
like it's maked he's using if you read
that text he's actually using the image
of creation he's he's actually he's
actually bringing us back into the
garden and he's telling that story again
and he's telling us like where his place
is he doesn't tell us what the thorn is
cuz it doesn't matter what the thorn is
we all have these thorns like we can all
know what it could be and we all you
know we get a sense of what it could be
and does it really matter but I think
that it's showing us this it's showing
us and so okay so let's do it this way
let's do this we're in terms of the
completing the sufferings of Christ so
okay so the the left hand is let's say
going away moving out so it's you can
imagine going out down into fire let's
say you can also imagine going up around
into fire so there's a relationship
between death and glory there's a
relationship with between that which
moves out
and what Gloria is like a crown is
something which is added which is
useless which is which is it's all these
it the crown actually has more left hand
symbolism then than anything because
it's this ornamental thing that you add
on top it's not part of the thing like
you say you have a chair and you have
the identity of the chair right it's a
chair ness of the chair and then you
have you put a pane of flour on it
what does that flour have to do with the
chair has nothing to do with the chair
it has nothing to do with the chair
nests of the chair you're putting a
flower on it to make it different from
other chairs so you can be different
from other chairs in a bad sense like
you can be different from others in a
bad sense in the sense that you're
falling away but you can also be
different in a way that is higher and
shows the glory of that chair so if I
want to make that chair special then I
make put something on top of its
identity in order to mark it as special
and that's glory so I'm not losing
anybody with that one
getting into me too hard difficult
things yeah two more okay so yeah you
two okay so good
[Music]
changing things have been known to
happen but hmm I I still think that I
still think that the the best way is to
look in first and then look out like
that's the way I see it it's like if you
understand Christianity and if you if
you dive into our own stories if you
dive into Scripture and the relationship
between Scripture and icons or the
relationship between that and the
liturgy and the architecture then then
that will give you the right eye to then
look out I think that's the best way to
do it so I tell people you know it's
like read I always point B with the same
the same books of the fathers these are
the key I'm telling you guys so so
Sanger venice'
life of Moses that book is has
everything in it so you're attentive you
read just the second part if you know
the story Moses you don't have to read
the first part three the second part
that book has everything in it it is one
it's one of the shining jewels of our
tradition send it from the seer in hymns
of paradise that book has so much in it
and you you have to be careful because
you can read through a paragraph and
you're like read through the paragraphs
like no no no read every line in that
paragraph and every line I could unpack
for hours there's this crazy place in
the internet from a poem where he says
he goes talks about paradise then he
says like Noah in the ark then he says
like the tabernacle like Moses ascending
the mountain like and he just goes talk
Johnson he just names him one after the
other and and if you're attentive is
like your mind's gonna explode because
he's basically taking all scripture and
he's saying you want to know what
paradise is you want to understand it
here I'm
tell you and I'm gonna give you all the
images in scripture that are have the
same pattern as the pattern of paradise
and you just knocks them out in like one
paragraph and you go crazy so so I I
think that I think st. gregory of nyssa
stand out from the Syrian and I think
st. Maximus in terms of in terms of the
theory in terms of understanding the
manner in which the Logie come together
and the manner in which that is also us
coming together in love how that all
fits becomes like a worldview that you
can live in I think st. Maximus gives us
the the key to that and so and then
after that I mean you know I there's
nothing better in the modern world there
are some symbolist that are in the
modern world my brother wrote a book
he's not Orthodox but he has a very very
he has a very sharp eye in terms of
understanding the patterns in Scripture
and there are there are a few people
that that have written you can read
Kaposi less comment on on the liturgy
you you get and it's hard because it's
so the father is also they they'll do
this in a way that isn't like they'll
talk about anime they'll give you like
this amazing tidbit but it's not in a
book about that so it's like you're
reading their thing and it's like oh
it's like this and then they they say
something crazy like that a Samson it
was at Saint Irenaeus on he says
something like Samson is one of the
figures in the Old Testament is closest
to Christ like what did you just say
that and then it's like okay okay I have
to unpack that because I trust you so
I'm gonna have to unpack how is it this
Samson is is one of the closes it's like
is the closest to the Incarnation is
Samson because you'd think you wouldn't
think that right anyway so but that's
harder because then it's like as you're
reading the fathers and as you're
reading sometimes in the services you
know you're going through the service
and all of a sudden some some phrase you
know some him just pops out and it's as
if it's giving you the keys to reality
you know especially in the especially
during the the whole Paschal season
during during that time like there's
some of the some of those hymns that are
just they blow your mind
so sorry I can't give you too much like
that but it's it's all there
I won last one I'm in one of those
churches so I I sympathize with you or
you see that Western structures no I I
think there is I think we do what we can
with what we have I think that we have
to this is my advice to all of you as
you become priests the the trick is to
not pretend that's the trick seriously
don't pretend don't pretend that you
have something you don't and I think
that's one of the problems with the
culture of reproductions is that it's
like we want to go into the our church
and have an entire iconographic program
and and and it's like so then we're just
gonna buy all these prints and plaster
them on the walls it's like okay you
know it's not and not saying it's
heretical there's nothing there's
nothing there's nothing ultimately wrong
about it but I think that there's
there's a the if the approach is lacking
I think I would rather you have one
beautiful icon of Christ and start there
because it's all in there anyways it's
all in that icon and so you know you if
you have a building that doesn't have a
dome I would suggest to explore the the
possibility of having Christ in the East
rather than you know you could you see
go into church it has a low ceiling it's
like this little rental place that were
10 foot ceiling it got indeed try to put
like a image
the piano credit like that doesn't
you're pretending you're not in in in
Constantinople it's like it's not
happening and and that's okay and that's
okay to not be in Constantinople so I
would say that and so it's like no so
that's what I say do move slowly get few
beautiful things and and don't you don't
have to fill the whole space so I'd
rather you have a you know I'd rather
you have a few things and have
spray-painted gold everything very much
so
so that's my suggestion so everybody
thank you so much for your time and your
attention
[Applause]